we begin this morning with the rapidly
deteriorating situation in ukraine where
russian forces are closing in on the
capital kiev and are bombarding and have
surrounded the strategically important
port city of mary opal ukraine's
president suggested the war has reached
a strategic turning point as the
shelling of neighboring cities
intensifies the u.s is deploying
additional troops to eastern europe to
support nato forces it's also sending
more weapons and billions of dollars in
aid to ukraine on friday president biden
reiterated his position that no american
soldier soldiers will go into battle
amid the developments the civilian death
toll is surging in the third week of the
offensive our coverage begins with chris
livesay in odessa in southern ukraine
chris good morning
good morning well here in ukraine's last
major coastal stronghold the city is
bracing for a major offensive as
civilians further up the black sea coast
were awakened to the sounds of fierce
battle
in the black seaport of mikolayev the
night offers no rest
among the rubble a cancer hospital
in an effort to break ukraine off from
vital access to the sea russian shelling
has broken infrastructure broken homes
and broken families now forced to live
here women and children in a basement
beneath a derelict market two weeks ago
they were playing hide and seek now
they're hiding from banned cluster bombs
according to the local government their
cold and dark bunker will only get
fuller in the days ahead says the mayor
alexander senkovic but i mean attacking
civilians is this on purpose
i think the the main idea is to kill
ukrainians as much as they can it's
complete liar when they say that they
want to protect us they want to kill as
much ukrainians as they can
across ukraine those brave enough to
step outside find their cities mutilated
the contested eastern city of bonavaja
is now in the teeth of russian
separatists brandishing a trademark z to
show their loyalty to putin
tanks were pounding the house so we just
prayed here says elizabeth
a grim fate ukrainians are fighting
tooth and nail to prevent city by city
from keeve to marijuana and up the coast
to here in micolaiv
this road leads to the next major port
town that's already fallen into russian
hands and the people of this town are
doing everything they can do to make
sure that they're not next lining the
road with tires they can set a blaze
and molotov cocktails
compared to russian firepower with the
second largest air force in the world
it's an unfair fight
but it's a fight they can't afford to
lose
and it's not only shelling civilians
have to fear in the occupied city of
melatuple russian soldiers captured the
mayor put a bag over his head and in
broad daylight took him to an
undisclosed location jeff
all right wow chris thank you very much